thank you for coming and glad of your
interest on this topic so yeah i'm
ricardo corral ricardo corral i'm
studying a PhD on biochemical sciences
at the national university of mexico so
what I'm going to show you is part of my
research i'm also a with data scientists
at suggesting in this company we try to
improve people's health by suggesting
Dietetic and lifestyle plants base with
machine learning technologies mainly
okay well first what are proteins and
proteins are the most abundant kind of
macromolecules a in cells they are
responsible of life itself as we know it
because they perform a large range of
activities these activities of proteins
are deal mainly to the protein structure
and that's why it's important to study
protein structure information about the
protein composition is encoded in the
DNA DNA is transcribed to RNA and
finally we have a sequence of amino
acids every protein is made up of this
20 amino acids a single sequence and
they fold by many biochemic physical
chemical properties of the amino acids
so what we got
in a protein is something like this it's
a very big molecule it has a lot of
atoms and it's pretty difficult to see
any kind of pattern here so biochemist
like to draw proteins did this way amino
acids tend to have to kind of local
interactions these are called alpha
helixes like this and beta sheets like
this otherwise these elements are called
secondary structure and I forgot to tell
the main amino acid sequence is called
also primary sequence okay these local
arrangements are called secondary
structure and the global structure of
the protein in three-dimensional space
is tertiary structure ok so there's
there are many false many kind of
structures that protein kind can have
this is a first attempt to try to
represent what is called default space 4
space is like a conceptual framework
where you can put any idea about protein
structure or function or evolution for
example if you want to say that two
protein structures are very similar you
can say that they are closed in this
whole space you can reconstruct this
whole space by comparing each pair of
proteins in your data set and then try
try to assign a particular position
in order to maintain these distances the
problem with this approach is that there
are as many false favorite presentations
are as data set so what we need is a way
to obtain this position in fall space
given only the protein structure only
structural features we don't know in any
anything about or other structures
another way of representing a protein
structure is by its contact map a
contact map it's a representation of the
contact between every pair of residues
sorry amino acids are called residuals
if they are inside a protein okay if I
see safe residuals I mean an amino acid
inside a protein so when two residues
are near each other they are in contact
so you can have a graph where each
vertex is a residue and each edge
represents that those residues are in
contact are closing in the structure and
a residue cluster is like a
generalization of this concept so you
can have more than two residues in
contact if all of them are in contact
with each other so for example here we
have three clusters okay that this is
equivalent to klikiss maximal clickers
that are complete sub graph of the
contact map
okay and for example yeah here we have
also for klikiss of size 3 but they are
not taken into account and that's the
spiny property not cluster is inside
another cluster so we are considering on
only the bigger the biggest cluster is
possible and it's interesting this
relationship between the size of the
proteins that is the number the total
number of amino acids and versus the
total number of clusters it is very
regular among any kind of proteins so
counting total number of clusters cannot
be a description descriptor for for
protein structure but if we distinguish
the clusters by how residues are in
primary sequence we for example have all
of these are examples of clusters of
size 4 but they are different because
the continuity in primary sequence is
distinct this is an simplified example
of how a protein looks like in in
three-dimensional space here if each
four of these residuals are safely in
contact to the day for my eight cluster
so the total number of clusters is is
the same if this part were very
different but if we count how many times
are these kind of Gloucester's these
counting's becomes a good descriptor of
of all of these form of the shape of the
trajectory so this is idea of getting
accounting classes of clusters in in
proteins so it is possible to describe
the entire shape of the protein only
counting how many times each class of
ratio clusters are in proteins there are
26 the Scriptures because the maximum
size of clusters is 6 the minimum size
is 3 and see if you take into account
all these variations of the same cluster
you'll end up with 26 okay so we have a
lot of atomic positions okay and we end
up with a single point in 26 dimensions
that represents all that complexity okay
and the position will be in this 26
dimensional space is determined by the
structural features of the protein okay
there are
two main structural classifications
database databases these are
hierarchical first level of
classification the sea level has to be
with the class which means the secondary
structure content so we have all the
proteins that have mainly alpha helixes
and the proteins with beta sheets only
and we have the config combination apart
and then a further classification is
made accordingly to the overall shape of
the protein without taking into account
very fine details and in the last level
of classification we have the topology
which is very sensitive to to difference
and similarities but this is how our
representation of fall space looks like
each color represents its class as is
given by by cut but by this database
well it's clear to see that proteins
belonging to the same classification are
in a defined free journey in this basin
and that's very good we made a
statistical test of how well this
representation of false base splits
different classes I'm not going into the
details here but it reduces to an
hypothesis testing and
the result was that this representation
indeed is separable by by the
classification scheme given by this
database so when learning the
classifications given this
representation these are the accuracies
doing cross validation with ten
iterations it's pretty cool and it's
very stable between the falls and we
made this experiment of training and
testing over the same data set it is not
recommended if you want to evaluate the
your capacity to predict new samples but
in this case these examples that cannot
be correctly classified even if they
were shown to the classifier in the
training set means that the complexity
of the model is not enough to
discriminate this poor examples that
means for example that there are many
elements many proteins of undress in
class and there are just one element
that is assigning to another class but
it's like if this examples forth for say
something they are very difficult
because they are in a region by class
grain bar officially they belong to the
class my hand
how these examples look like is
something like this you can see in here
there are elements of secondary
structure being alpha Alex and beta
sheets and so our classifier classifiers
say it is actually alpha and beta but
officially this should be a mainly beta
which is at least it's not so accurate
this example is classified for by our
classifier as being mainly beta but
officially cut this should be alpha and
beta this thing is classified as has few
secondary structure but officially it is
mainly beta and this one which is
classified as as mainly alpha should be
a few secondary structure so we have a
way to identify very hard assignments of
classifications of all the structures by
by doing this this experiment of
training and testing over over the same
data set
so we can replicate some given
structural classification there's
another similar problem that is a
protein structural neighbor retrieval
and the setup of the problem is if you
if we have a protein structure and a new
protein structure and a database with
protein structures what are the proteins
more similar to the query protein and
it's very difficult because usually you
need to compare the similarity between
two protein structures you try to
superimpose one over the other this is
computationally expensive it's not so a
curator at all for example these two
proteins have a very high score when
they are aligned because all this part
aligns perfectly with this segment and
so the score when you compare the
structures is very high but it does not
reflect the similarity you are looking
for so you have two criteria okay let's
define this these classes are SAS is a
score for structural superposition such
20 means that this score is less than
two angstroms from one structure to the
other this should be less than three or
five and this should be less than five
so this is very
restrict restrictive well this is more
relax these are classifications as given
by a scope that the other data is that
is not cut to structural classification
and it's interesting that here we have
the fraction of pairs of proteins that
are under this level of similarity that
belongs to the same classification at
families per family topology address so
what it's suspected is that this
fraction is very close to 1 because you
call identify members of the same class
by just doing comparisons but it's not
the case you have a very tiny fraction
of our members of same class that can be
identified only by this score ok so
doing structural alignment is not enough
to know when two structures belong to
the same class so the state of the art
for this problem is contact leaf they
measure the capacity of identify
structural universe by sorting by some
criteria of similarity and they see how
how well front are the pairs of proteins
that belong to the same class for this
problem a real structural Nate never is
okay two proteins are real neighbors if
they are under under these criteria of
structural superposition and also are
inside the same superfamily you need to
meet both criteria to say that two
structures are really neighbors these
are our salt Oh compare directly with
contact lip we are a little well it's
almost the same at this level we perform
a little better on the next levels and
the way of doing this is given a query
structure we can predict its
classification and then the score of the
neighbor is how much the classifier
thinks the other structures belong to
the predicted class and so you can check
this this linked this is how the protein
structure information is stored it has a
lot of data but the most important part
is is this here you have each of the
atoms that has the protein and you have
coordinates in XJ and see
so the idea is as I told you how to
transform all of these coordinates in a
single point and in practice the only
you need to do is to create an object
with the file in PDF format that is the
format i showed you and a particular
chain proteins may be made of more than
one chain so you need to specify why
change you're interested in this vector
is computed as at construction time so
you can see the result in this variable
it's it doesn't take so much and so you
can download all the domain definitions
of these databases gut and scope and I
have this peg computed database you have
a domain ID the 26 dimensional vector
and the classification under this
database so you can use psychic learn to
do a lot of Mike with this first thing
we can do is reduce the dimensionality
of this space to try to see how the
structure is you can see make a plot of
every pair of variables but it is better
to try to compact all of this
information in the number of dimensions
you want so here I'm using icing up
plotting the the results with d zeta set
looks something like this is very
similar to the image i receive for this
is a compact data set in order to make
these competitions more quickly then
this is an adaptation of the Elena's
tutorial for say you can make some hyper
parameter selection with this and plot
the combination of parameters that are
more suitable and you can use also this
other function to to calculate the
cross-validation the cross-validated
score cycling have a function to
calculate this but you miss all of the
details in each iteration so you can use
this dysfunction to see all the details
in each iteration so you can play a
little trying to improve these these
accuracies here are some of the formal
details they are not so funny at all so
there are still so many databases that
have information about protein
structures and the ideas that you can
try to learn any kind of classifications
with this same structural representation
we can do all of this if we already have
the protein structure I mean the
positions of each atom in the
three-dimensional space but a big
problem in computational biology is to
determine to predict the structure
giving only the sequence so there's a an
international experiment called clasp so
they have new proteins they know the
structure but they only open the
sequence so any research group can make
their predictions and see who can do the
work better and this is very interesting
this is a any match from a last review
of the advances of this experiment what
you are seeing here is each point is the
best research group that predicts the
protein structure and here you have
underscore of similarity between the the
model the prediction and the real
structure and this target difficulty is
how similar is the query structure the
decreased sequence with known sequences
so
when predicting protein structure a lot
of approaches make use of sequence
similarity if you know sequences that
are very similar to the sequence of
interest is very easy to to predict the
structure but it's very difficult when
you're quite sequence have no has no
direct similarity with sequences you
know so this study difficulty tries to
summarize this effect so it is more
difficult if the more similar sequence
we know is not so similar at all it's
pretty sad that this tendency hasn't
changed since almost 20 years because
all of the approaches still rely in
having direct similarity so what we can
do is not trying to predict directly the
structure but the representation of this
structure so if you can have a
attributes to represent a protein
sequence you can map this sequence to
the corresponding vector in the 2016
dimensional space I'm not going into the
details of how these attributes for
protein sequence are generated but the
ideas once you have your attributes from
the sequence you can learn for
every of the 26 numbers of the
structural fall space and then you
retrain your classifier in this
predicted space so you have used set of
sequences you have a set of non
structures and their vectors you have
classifications based on structure so
you can have a sequence predict this
representation in 2060 mentions and then
replicate some structural classification
and here is an experiment made on this
topology timber oil is the most is the
biggest family structural family known I
mean there are a lot of proteins that
falls in the same money but there are a
lot of sequence families very dissimilar
with each other so you have a group of
sequences belonging to this this
topology you have another group of
sequences also belong belonging to this
topology and have no so much similarity
with these with these groups so if we if
this approach works
and we can eliminate the necessity of
having direct similar of the direct
sequence similarity we should be able to
predict a structural class for a
sequence family given no other example
of that family to the training set each
point here is represent a sequence
family all the elements in this family
are very similar which is each other the
idea is to train with all the available
data except for for this family and then
given this set of sequences we predict
the 26 dimensional vector and over this
space we predict the class we want to
see if this class is in this timber an
accuracy is how many of the members of
this family were correctly assigned to
this topology and difficulty is as a
finance before how how close is the
closest known sequence it is very
interesting that we have good results in
this cases when many other approaches
just cannot make good predictions
because there are no similar sequences
oh I think it's all because I'm out of
town also so questions you very much
regard Oh a little bit one of the one of
the reasons why I picked this to cover
the pie later is I want to see how
things have changed as someone who's
worked with doing protein folding before
and the strategies you've got now you
say that mean the really hasn't been a
lot of change with getting better
accuracy with the classifiers just
wanted to see them that some of the deep
learning algorithms that you've got
pegged there have you got any early data
from doing those strategies you have
that one graph about the tin barrel
family have you try for the other
families is there any yeah there's some
success in the other areas as well I'm
starting this experiment because the
evaluation of when family takes from
nine to 12 hours and there are more than
2,000 families so I need more than two
years but i'm working on a distributed
environment so i can in parallel to all
these experiments and i hope to have all
the families evaluated by two months or
so yeah i need any questions for record
I can slightly easy or more the 26
predictors well could you just explain
that again Faison series residue kids
but I wasn't yeah the the class of the
receipt receipt or cluster is or is it
they're mine by sequence continuity okay
so if you have for example clusters of
size 33 residues may be contiguous or
you can have to continues and one
discontinuous or all the tree can be
discontinuous so for a cluster of size 3
you only have three classes okay four
clusters of size four you have more
possible classes and so on so I've used
sum up all of the possibilities of
classes of clusters of size three to six
you got 26 right waiting in each time
and call it that record is wrap the rest
of day having more questions for him but
thank you very much for kung fu time